Portrayed with affable charm by Jorge Garcia,
Hurley was the heart and soul of Lost, but
in his post-Lost life, the actor has kept
a relatively low profile despite working constantly.
Here's a look at what he's been up to since
bidding farewell to the island.
Following his star-making turn on Lost, Garcia
didn't waste much time booking his next gigs.
It should come as no surprise that those gigs
came via his pal, Lost co-creator J.J. Abrams.
First up was a brief, but hilariously memorable
turn as a bong-wielding security officer on
Abrams' under-appreciated sci-fi series Fringe.
"And you're the best boss I've ever had."
Garcia followed that cameo with a much bigger
role on another Abrams series, the short-lived
crime drama Alcatraz.
The show followed a young San Francisco detective
as she tried to unravel the mystery behind
the return of several long-deceased inmates
of the infamous island prison.
Garcia played Dr. Diego Soto, a paranoid conspiracy
theorist who also happens to be an expert
on all things Alcatraz.
Garcia's comedic chops have continued to land
him roles on television, including a couple
of episodes of one of the biggest sitcoms
of all time, How I Met Your Mother.
He made his first appearance on the show in
2010 as Steve "The Blitz" Henry, an old college
friend of Marshall and Ted's.
Much like Hurley, The Blitz appears to be
cursed with rotten luck, as he got his nickname
because he missed something amazing every
time he left a party early.
The episode also makes clever use of Garcia's
Lost background by using his cursed lottery
numbers as a phone number.
Garcia would reprise the role for another
brief but memorable cameo in the show's final
season, when we see that The Blitz's luck
hasn't changed all that much over the years.
"Yes!
Whoo!"
"Aww, man!"
Unlike The Blitz, Garcia has had pretty good
luck in his own life, as he continues to book
notable supporting roles on popular TV shows.
He even went back to his fantasy roots for
ABC's long-running fairy tale drama Once Upon
a Time.
Garcia appeared on three episodes of the show
between 2012 and 2013.
In a case of pitch-perfect casting, he landed
the role of Anton, a magic bean-hoarding,
surprisingly short giant with a fear of humans.
"That's right, run!"
Unfortunately, though, Garcia didn't share
any screen time with his former Lost costar
Emilie de Ravin, who was a Once Upon a Time
regular as Belle.
Garcia's most surprising cameo came in 2010,
when the actor's smiling face graced the cover
of Weezer's eighth album, the aptly titled
Hurley.
Yes indeed, the album was actually named after
Garcia's beloved Lost character.
As frontman Rivers Cuomo explained, after
deciding to use a photo of Garcia as the cover
art, the band realized that fans would just
"refer to it as 'the Hurley record.'"
So it only made sense to beat them to the
punch.
Fortunately, the album didn't suffer its namesake's
generally rotten luck.
It received a warm critical reception and
debuted at number six on the Billboard 200.
In an even more surprising turn of events,
the band even invited Garcia to come perform
live with them on several tour stops supporting
the album, and honestly, he wasn't half bad.
Garcia worked hard to make his fans laugh
when he appeared in 2015's The Ridiculous
Six, a Netflix original movie packed with
the likes of Adam Sandler, Rob Schneider,
and about a dozen or so other men and women.
If you've never heard of Ridiculous Six, that's
probably because it wasn't very good.
In fact, it stands as one of the worst reviewed
films in Adam Sandler's career.
That being said, Garcia's turn as the unintelligible
Herm was one of the few jokes that actually
worked.
Although, considering the way the movie was
received, perhaps he'd rather forget he was
in the movie at all.
"I just wish somebody here could speak Herm."
Since 2013, Garcia has portrayed local conspiracy
theorist-slash-consultant Jerry Ortega on
CBS' long-running Hawaii Five-O reboot.
As it happens, it was the idea of a reunion
with his Lost costars Daniel Dae Kim and Terry
O'Quinn that led Garcia to take the role.
The role was initially set as a two-episode
cameo, but Garcia was so good in the part
that producers quickly promoted him to series
regular.
Now he has no plans on leaving the popular
series anytime soon.
That's no surprise, considering the perk of
shooting on the island paradise of Oahu, which
happens to be where the majority of Lost was
shot as well.
While we're happy that Garcia has scored some
steady work, we're also a little worried that
he's back on the island he worked so hard
to get away from.